[Music]
oh man it is the painful landing that
may have just changed the fate of who
will win Dancing with the Stars you know
a lot of people thought normani would
take home that Mirrorball trophy next
week but now what we have the latest on
the busted dance move that has rocked
the ballroom Oh God Oh me yesterday
normani twisted her right ankle after
attempting a split we didn't land well
oh you're hearing this table bow held
her off but with normanni later laying
on the floor and pain things weren't
looking good
should I get you eyes yeah just like let
me ice it for like ten minutes
Monday's the finale and this duo are the
frontrunners to win and she recovering
time
how's your back it's getting better well
the fifth harmony singer is a pass
healer last month she overcame an injury
straining her back I can actually get up
out of it by myself now my mom had to
the whole days after visiting the doctor
she fought her way through to get
perfect school
[Music]
today she was back rehearsing with her
partner and Instagram this video with a
rapt angle a source tells ET Norman he's
in pain but fighting through it but will
she and bow scrap this move Romani has
said her biggest obstacle is her and
vows stubbornness have you had to modify
anything that you've done choreography
wise because of her injury a very little
I mean last week just because I'm super
stubborn and she's really stubborn
anything work and and you know and that
always kind of lingers on the line of a
stupidity me guarantee when it's game
time she'll be ready to play shall
perservere
[Music]
you